before you get born again revisit the
trilogy that made the world realize a
gift from Good Will Hunting and kick
some serious ass I thought that Matt
Damon was like a Streisand but think
that he's rocking the shitness ones the
Bourne trilogy experienced the gritty
realistic world of the Bourne franchise
full of bone-crunching action that feels
like it's really happening spy
technology that feels grounded in
reality and the signature camerawork
that feels like someone strapped a GoPro
to a method man that is shaky
it's really hard to follow guys looking
kinda dizzy
why did I think it was a good idea to
sit in the front row oh oh I think I'm
gonna be sick me bored Jason Bourne the
spy who made that eras James Bond look
like a joke he's a badass assassin with
the skills of Liam Neeson and taken but
the brain of durian Finding Nemo Who am
I where am I I can't remember anything
that happened before two weeks ago I
don't even know who I'm hiding from I
don't know who I am I don't know where
I'm
I don't know what happened I don't know
who this guy was I don't know about that
picture I don't know who I am I don't
remember what happened in Marseille
something's wrong with you really write
a law with this deadly dummy who's
forgotten everything except all the
useful stuff like how to weaponize an
entire Staples catalogue it's super
bribing I'll give you $10,000 to drive
me to Paris Oh God honey a bunch of
other skills that don't seem very
relevant I can tell you the
license-plate numbers of all six cars
outside I can tell you that our
waitresses left-handed and the guy
sitting up at the counter weighs 215
pounds now why would I know that and his
signature move the old come alone you
come alone send her alone come alone
slip away I'm gone where the hell is he
cannot afford to lose the sky people
so revisit three pulse-pounding thrill
rides that couldn't be more different
from those long boring books on sale at
the airport the Bourne Identity we're
born tries to figure out who he is has a
cool car chase and runs from a control
room full of people on computers only to
discover the crooked government guy
chasing him was just a puppet for
someone else the Bourne Supremacy we're
bored tries to figure out why he is who
he is has a cool car chase and runs from
a control room full of people on
computers only to discover the crooked
government guy chasing him was just a
puppet for someone else and the Bourne
Ultimatum we're poor tries to figure out
who made him who he is has a cool car
chase and runs from a control room full
of people on computers only to discover
that the crooked government guy chasing
him was just a puppet for someone else
hey if it ain't broke don't fix it story
Jason Vaughn grumpy old man cameos Tommy
Lee Jones ten Things I Hate about spies
gun control
you
tactical monaco ligue old-ass computer
monitors looking worried while walking
through a train station
people saying assets find out what kind
of local assets we have a place there
what do you want Stan but Xactimate the
asset assets on scene tell me when the
assets in the nest could be our set of
green light will there be an asset up in
Casablanca give the asset subject
location the asset is deviating off
course asset unscheduled asset is on the
move send the asset after her send the
asset after them asset confirms both
targets are down the asset lost form add
like a million turtlenecks finding
boardy David Webb it's your real name
you were born for 1571 and Nixon
Missouri
so he's just some dude from Missouri
named David that's it International
super spy Jason Bourne sounds way cooler
bro be sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers
Arthur curry I hear you can talk to fish
many Bothans died to bring you this
honest trailer like a good Butler Alfred
is there Bob Loblaw Bob's law Bob my
pokemons
let me show them to you chuck norris
caught all the pokemon with a landline
phone
oh that's right we forgot that jeremy
renner born movie existed admitted you
did too